all right Jeremy is with us Jeremy is in
San Antonio hi Jeremy how are you I'm
doing great Dave good how can I help
I had a timeshare question we had just
went to my mom and dad's timeshare and
while we were there sit down for a
meeting and on the salesmen tried to
sell me my wife one until this put it
all on a credit card that's a guy have
you ever heard of Dave Ramsey and he
told me he was your personal financial
adviser he told me what he said what he
told us that he used to be your personal
financial adviser and he told you three
times heirs but what else right that's
what we did a timeshare salesman said he
was my personal financial adviser that's
what he Picard skies guy this guy's got
anatomical attributes Dundee I mean he
really he's got guts I'll just tell you
he did have it
he had pick up knee he also claimed he
said how do you think Dave sells all of
his stuff you have to call in and give
him a credit card now he does accept
credit card oh that's funny it is
seriously funny no I've never owned a
timeshare I've made every financial
mistake I think known to man except that
one I never bought a timeshare and
and I didn't have the financial mistake
of having a timeshare salesman as my
financial advisor either I can assure
you that this guy I mean you could tell
he was lying if his mouth was moving
good yet funny absolutely
where was this it was in it was in
Missouri Branson in Branson Missouri I
got her and I'm sure Tom shares are big
there oh my Wow
we at least know one characters out
there that's up in it funny people
people are so short-sighted that they
think if they just make up stuff that
that you're so gullible you'll go along
I know absolutely it was it was
incredible so yeah that's a blast Jeremy
well thanks for sharing the stuff
I appreciate it that's something else oh
what a mess what a mess
listen timeshares folks I mean that's
just straight-up stupid ever bite I'm
sure never bite I'm sure never buy a
timeshare never buy timeshare they're
just like a 97% customer dissatisfaction
you're stuck in them you can't get out
there's no market for him because you
don't own anything you can't sell them
you're stuck in it and so it becomes
this consumption thing and with what
you've spent you could have stayed in
the freakin Ritz
you know it's because taken yeah Four
Seasons or something you spent on that
week it's $14,000 you gotta be getting
me yeah well people do it all the time
and it's a really really really dumb
idea hope I wasn't unclear hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a five
hundred thousand dollar income
you